hier des militants de l'association
droit des animaux ont empêché une partie
de chasse en forêt de saint-gobain en
décembre dernier déjà la mise à mort
d'un cerf avait fait beaucoup parler de
lui dans c'était ça cela s'était passé
dans un jardin chez un particulier
les deux camps ont besoin de convaincre
et cela passe parfois par le recours aux
groupes de pression thierry curtet et
dida ans ont suivi un lobbyiste en
pleine action auprès de député picard
il défend les intérêts des chasseurs cet
homme fait la loi
il n'est pourtant ni sénateur ni députés
non son métier consiste à influencer les
parlementaires ou à leur soutirer des
informations
je suis un mercenaire donc je défend des
intérêts des gens qui payent je ne
choisis pas nécessairement les causes
ses clients des industriels de
l'environnement de l'agroalimentaire des
armuriers est aujourd'hui déjà ce côté
là la clé va bien poignée de main
tutoiement avec un député de droite
plutôt favorable aux idées de ses
clients voilà ils sont
jérôme bignon doit participer bientôt à
un congrès de chasseurs justement en
présence du ministre de l'environnement
le lobbyiste le pousse à s'engager à
intervenir
ça vaudrait le coup qui leur fasse une
une note quand même que je saute aux
yeux
tandis que j'ai un petit un petit
pense-bête aussi envie cela je veux pas
intervenir
et pourquoi il est parti le député ne
vois pas là une ingérence juste des
intérêts partagés
la poisse mais c'est lundi prochain moi
j'ai 6000 chasseurs dans les
circonscriptions où les chasseurs ils
tous les tous les autres parce que si je
si vous saviez le monde que je vois le
nombre de lobbies que je reçois où le
nombre de professions je reçois sur
l'énergie sur les vétérinaires sur les
agriculteurs du tarn on passe notre
temps à ça le lobbyiste doit compter des
relations à droite comme à gauche
vous allez voir qu'ils maintiennent g
est député communiste parce qu'il défend
bien les chasseurs et surtout c'est un
très bon porte-parole tutoie la bise aux
députés communistes ils sont plus aussi
de nombreux chasseurs parmi ses
électeurs mais le lobby après c'est sûr
tous les coups de gueule du député de la
somme il leur arrive même d'écrire
ensemble des amendements une pratique
courante à l'assemblée je fais pas le
tri je regarde les amendements il
correspondre à ce que je pense ou pas
partir de là s'ils correspondent à ce
que je pense je vais pas me gêner
la cre a d'ailleurs sur son bureau 25
propositions pour amender la loi sur
l'hôpital
envoyé par un groupe d'associations
maxime gremetz explique qu'il s'en est
servi pour écrire 14 de ses propres
amendements
la véritable opposition pour thierry
costes ce sont les écologistes ils
tentent en ce moment de négocier avec
eux et de vieux combats ont laissé des
traces
l'intérêt général mais lui défend des
intérêts particuliers
il est payé par des gens pour dire bon
tu fonces que nous fait le truc et puis
tu combats des députés de la majorité et
malheureusement ça marche parce qu'il
est assez efficace et ça le problème
dans ce métier pour durer thierry costes
se fixe une limite
une seule convaincre sans corrompre il
nous affirme qu'il n'est jamais question
des changes d'argent dans ses relations
il lui arrive même d'être désintéressé
jamais très longtemps tiens écosse a
rendu un service au patron du voilier la
boudeuse
en retour il est informé des personnes
présentes à ces soirées et cocktails
vous avez envie de rencontrer le
directeur de cabinet de jean louis
borloo qui avait promis qu'il venait et
j'avais envie de la rencontrer dans un
endroit plus sympa le directeur de
cabinet n'est pas venu pas grave il sait
déjà où le croiser demain sur paris il
existe une vingtaine de cabinets de
lobbying qui agissent sans aucune
réglementation
[Musique]